he is a Matt Walsh actor comedian
director writer really a very very funny
guy and he'll prove that coming up here
the series finale of veep airs this
Sunday on HBO is that why you're joining
us to talk about this series finale it's
the victory lap I'm taking but but it's
ending it's not like Curb Your
Enthusiasm where there's a chance it
could come back this is it yeah the TV
show has ended I think there's like a
rumor we might come back and do like a
movie or something or you know but
there's no nothing planned at all it is
our final season well who's the one
that's spreading the rumor aside from
you I think we're all sort of rooting
for it because we all still get along
and would love to do something so I've
heard it from Dave our head writer he's
like yeah maybe but HBO has not offered
us a movie No
how long does the rehearsal take oh the
seasons take oh god it's a good question
I don't know months at a time the
writers will break story for a couple
months and then will come in in the
third month probably and then we'll get
two or three scripts and then every
script that gets read we sort of
rehearse the things that aren't working
and then the season is up and running
and then usually by midseason the wheels
fall off the cart and we're chasing it
for the rest of the year but it's the
timing is so important on V yeah and so
to get that down but you have to have
familiarity with everybody and
understand sort of their cadence there
but that's why I'm curious about okay
there you know when you're trying to
shoot a scene yeah we own the character
so yeah so we always you never memorize
your lines on veep because you know in
the morning they're gonna give you a
brand new version of the scene so you
sort of familiarize yourself with the
beats unless you have a giant monologue
then you really get it right but you
just sort of go okay and then you know
when you walk in you're gonna get a
brand new scene and then we'll rehearse
without camera we'll just kind of
rehearse the beats and figure out the
choreography and the sort of ways to
make it funny or find props and make it
funnier and then even pitch bits to add
to the script and then we'll rehearse
with camera because camera is like the
missing magic because they know a lot of
times you focus on the guy who's not on
camera for the punchline you don't I
mean or the insult is on him even though
he's saying it the cameras on you so
they're a big part
the dance and then once we have camera
figured out then we'll get in and start
rehearsing and it's such rapid-fire that
you can't be offended by anything
because you move on so quickly to the
next line and everybody gets it nobody
avoids being like just shredded verbally
just the most and it's the best written
show on TV yeah I've been called a sad
egg a gay Irish fireman both true both
true yeah but but we were taught a gay
egg though oh you're not gay Irishman
the other like this I love when I would
look at your bio this is the one thing
that stood out and it's gonna surprise
you huh while in high school he played
on the football team as a backup tight
in like you couldn't even why that you
started in high school man you're a
bastard on the special teams okay kick
off and I was a backup linebacker as
well but like most people lie a little
bit on their resume you you're proud
that you were a backup I may have put
that in there cuz I thought it was funny
and it's probably just held on oh it is
yeah that's true that is true now you
you played a lot of different characters
the doctor and the hangover mmm
dr. Walsh you were in elf yeah Ted yeah
played a rental car boss yeah favorite
role out of those movies that you buy
those I think a hangover was a magical
did you know it well no I knew it'd be
funny cuz I know those guys I know Zach
and Ed and I didn't really know Bradley
Cooper that much but I remember when we
filmed that scenes there was like two
days of filming and that was the day
that like Obama was elected to his first
election so we were like doing the scene
with a naked 85 year old man if you
remember the scene and that was really
awkward and Zach kept laughing so we had
to like reset reset reset and then in
between shooting we would go backstage
and check the results of like the
election it was like this crazy
memorable moment in my life so I you
always know I always felt like that
movie
would be really funny but you don't know
if it's gonna catch on and become like a
big big but zach galifianakis how why is
he the one that's breaking character
shouldn't a comedian be the last to
break characters I've work with Zach but
I worked with Zach on a show called dog
bites man and he's terrible at laughing
he's always cracking up
he's two ferns is spectacular it is
great just the stuff when like it's so
awkward like the Brad Pitt like I think
he said um to your great looks
overshadow you being a bad actor oh my
god then you can just see Brad Pitt gone
really and then he goes how did you get
so tanned because you're always in your
wife's shadow and I'm going Michael Cera
was on and he's grabbing his leg his
thigh I wonder if they're prepped on
those jokes depend like this Brad Pitt
know that joke joke is coming probably
not i unless you say hey i just i want
to come in Jennifer Aniston came in and
Zach Galifianakis is he wanted to talk
to Tila Tequila that reality star and
and Jen comes in as the secondary guest
and then she finally goes are you gonna
talk to me and and he's like he wanted
to talk to Tila Tequila Jennifer Aniston
aren't you glad I'm talking about Zach
Galifianakis while you're on the show
man it's diverting attention I'm trying
to take away the pressure of you being
really really sunny banana I've always
been a second oh it's okay Fritzie did
stand-up comedy
five times okay he's almost fifty years
of age how many times did you do
stand-up comedy before you were 50 I did
it in my late 20s in the comedy boom of
say like 89 to 91 and who's doing the
tour back then well I was in Chicago so
I was being promoted to headliner before
I was ready in the Train like Indiana
Michigan Wisconsin you were killing it I
could get paid like 400 bucks to go
headline for 40 minutes and I did not
have 40 minutes but it was like that
crazy like anybody with a joke could get
on stage and get paid so I got elevated
way too quick so I would bring people
like Adam McKay
with me or matt besser to sort of build
out my lack of material and we would
just do bits and sketches did you ever
crash like did you know my god every
other night yeah it's too hard
stand up is like it's great when it
works and it's brutal when it doesn't
and then when it's brutal you're in a
hotel room in like Farmington Michigan
and although all the comics are going
out there strip club and I'm like I'm
good I don't want to like it gets really
dark on the road and that's the other
bad part about stand-up so you do stay
in I just chilled out and just licked my
wounds and said I'm not really gonna be
a good standup are you yourself though
when you do stand-up are you just given
like a that this happened or is it a
character like it's happened in mine oh
it was my problem is I would always do a
character and then I wouldn't repeat it
then I would try something brand new the
next night it was like way too ambitious
and stand-up as that art of honing and
really tweaking and getting boiling it
down distilling it to that gem and I
didn't like that process because I came
up in the improv world and improvisers
like to just create create create create
so but the improvisational skills do you
know you have them can you develop those
yeah you can develop improv skills cuz
you're basically writing on your feet
and learning to make choices that
sustain a comic moment basically is what
you're learning and you're learning to
list and that's the other skill that you
really when you're a good improviser you
get better at listening Matt lives in an
exclusive area in Los Angeles and a lot
of famous people your most famous
neighbor is currently a meghan trainor
and melissa mccarthy okay but she's like
half a block away okay not neighbor and
you socialize a little bit yeah I do
around Christmas I'll break this is so
corny I'll bake like 50 loaves of soda
bread Irish soda bread grandma's recipe
and I'll deliver them to my neighbors
and I'll take the kids with me with the
wagon and we'll give the neighbors the
loaf of soda bread so that's about as
much like socializing unless I'm invited
like I won't show up uninvited to any of
their houses but have you been invited
yeah I know her brothers for example I
know Megan's brothers better than I know
her okay but but you go there and then
say hey neighbors yeah it's pretty
friendly but it's not like a regular
thing but not like a you know keg or
anything like that no keggers there's
usually an annual like Christmas party
that Melissa won't have that's fine yeah
I like it one offer if you want to do
comedy at Upright Citizens Brigade in
New York I can hook you up
Oh Fritzi yes Matt Wolff and we have a
venue downtown in like the village which
is perfect for like more of a solo night
called subculture downstairs I can make
that happen
that's very awesome that's really to
program a night for you
big-time comedian star of veep and he's
offering you an opportunity Upright
Citizens for Graham an evening you could
be the headliner he'd bring two openers
that's pretty cool that's that's
something I would do who wouldn't want
to do that with Matt while I was waiting
I won't be there I'll be in LA but
definitely make this happen
it's that a yes Todd yeah we do that no
that's really that's just my nerves
that's my nerves talking okay we can do
it you can advance it you know we can do
in a couple months you don't have to
feel like oh I got to get it ready now
all right it doesn't matter no well we
he's he's done a couple of them and he
went to Caroline's and he was at the
Comedy Store
yep so he's been in two of the legendary
places and I just said you know do you
want to do it anymore and any bombed a
couple of times and then he got down his
down those luck a little bit and I said
no this sort of like remember behind the
music where you'd say oh they they came
upon the scene like a meteor and then
you have crashing a crash and then this
was the comeback and then we realized
there was no comeback so we were gonna
have a just go away tour what do you
think of that where I think that's a
great gimmick so the just go your final
tour is it great just keep doing final
tours wherever you go it does seem too
low of it not working out on stage is a
lot lower than the high you get from you
know hitting a couple good ones and
making everybody laugh you know what's a
good option quitting I didn't quit I
just I said why did you gave up I didn't
have a specific date in mind just to do
it again
say I would never do it again and that
was that's very flattering and very
generous of Matt to have me try to
continue doing the con you just you're
driving everybody crazy here everybody's
got their head in their hands right now
going are you kidding me
all right forget it the the best line
that your character has ever delivered
on V if I said this line question this
line would sum up my okay one that comes
to mind is Selena I'm talking to the
press about something and she comes in
misunderstands that I've broken a story
about a kid with AIDS okay so her
perception of my conversation is like
you told him about the kid with AIDS so
we leave the room we're outside the
office and she and she says the mic
she says Mike wordid where did the AIDS
come from and Mike goes I think some guy
after monkey I should have done some
homework before I asked the same time
there Wow I you know I think sometime
perfect V blind we and it goes by so
quickly so - yes but we were talking
about Julia Louie Dreyfus and you know
she was you know Elaine on Seinfeld
where you're a character now she's
running and you now it's focused on her
yeah but that comedic timing that she
has I think it was underrated on
Seinfeld but now I think America
realizes just how brilliant she was as
Elaine on this character she's sort of
like the it's so cheesy but she's like
Lucille Ball like she's just the
dominant comedic force like she just is
amazing and tremendous work ethic
obviously and also like perfectionist in
the best way like wants to get it right
and like and and a joy to work with like
she's really she's really funny yeah
what was your role in Ted Ted was the
rental car agency boss were like
Warburton and Wahlberg work
and I was just like a dull boss I love
that movie yeah I don't remember me
I was trying to think the only thing I
can tom skerritt obsession I had the Tom
Skerritt obsession now does it remember
I the only thing I remember is the
checkout line with or the lotion scene
with with Ted I don't remember that
scene what's the theme yeah I don't
remember it honestly I swear to God
can you describe it no no okay no like
moving on I should wait but okay and
that made a half a billion dollars
didn't it yeah I bet it did yeah yeah
you got back-end right no like Robert
Downey jr. with Avengers you know
back-end no points no peace maybe a day
right so fritzy the offer is gonna stand
until the top of the hour and then the
offer disap it's gone then it's gone
okay I think he accepted but we'll we'll
revisit I guess the the last episode of
veep before they make it into a movie is
going to be this Sunday at Fritz you
have it at 10:50 East yes it is actually
10:50 did you know that now you're at
10:50 Eastern on Sunday night that's
weird I don't know why I didn't know
that special finale edition that's
Thrones
yeah Game of Thrones they want a pair of
this but they usually start on the hour
and just fill it with like promos for
the next [ __ ] like 10:15 yeah okay and
our show is act maybe because of that
our final episode is gonna be 40 plus
minutes I think yeah so maybe it's great
to see you yeah Congrats thank you for
having me yeah yeah and we'll see if
Fritz he'll take you up on the offer The
Upright Citizens Brigade a ping-pong
rematch 911 well that was great wasn't
you had a really good maybe do it again
I played in so long so that's my only
excuse yeah yeah but funny right was i
funny at ping-pong
mmm no dad am i dead am I the best
ping-pong player among the dance yes you
mr. sensitivity man thank you for coming
by thank you friend who's the actor
comedian occasionally funny director
me Sunday night at end of zach
galifianakis and Julia Dreyfus yeah
let's talk more about them for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app